Central banks spent five years hoarding
gold to escape the US dollar, but now
one country just did the opposite and
the reason has global markets looking on
nervously. In early 2026, Turkey's
central bank hit the panic button. They
dumped over 8 billion dollars of gold
reserves in just two weeks. It wasn't a
normal trade. They weren't cashing out
at the top. They were scrambling for
survival. Turkey's gold sell-off reveals
something far bigger. The global gold
hoard wasn't a coordinated attack
against the dollar. It was a financial
lifeline for countries trying to delay a
crisis. And now the question is, if
Turkey has had to sell the insurance
policy first, who's next? When a nation
starts selling off an asset it spent
years accumulating, it usually means
something has gone seriously wrong
behind the scenes. The money is getting
tighter, the pressure is building and
suddenly the thing they bought as
protection becomes the thing they have
to sell. That's exactly what happened in
Turkey earlier this year. At the end of
February 2026, the Central Bank of the
Republic of Turkey, or CBRT, dumped a
staggering 58.4 tons of gold worth
approximately 8 billion dollars and it
happened in just two weeks. But it was
only the beginning. By April, the total
had exploded to 128 tons of gold. To put
that into perspective, Turkey had wiped
out an amount equal to roughly 40% of
all the gold accumulated by every
emerging market central bank combined
throughout the entire year of 2025. And
that's what makes this so unusual.
Central banks don't usually treat gold
like a normal investment. They don't buy
it to chase returns or make short-term
bets. They hold when everything else
starts to fall apart, gold is one of the
few assets the world still trusts. It's
the financial equivalent of an emergency
exit and Turkey ran straight through
that exit. Not because they wanted to,
not because they saw a better
opportunity, because they had to. And
the reason comes down to one thing, the
Turkish lira. For years, the currency
has been in freefall and when a
country's currency starts collapsing, it
creates a chain reaction that can
quickly spiral out of control. To
understand why, you need to understand
what a currency actually represents.
National currency is like a gauge of a
country's reputation on the global
stage. Countries that have proven
themselves to be a reliable, trustworthy
financial partner have a much easier
time attracting investors from around
the world. This strengthens the value of
their currencies. The American dollar
and British pound are good examples of
this. But when a country loses that
trust, investors pull back, demand for
the currency falls, and the value of
that currency begins to weaken. That
usually happens when a country is
printing too much money, taking on too
much debt, and has political
instability, or is dealing with high
inflation rates. And that's what
happened to the lira. Its collapse was
the result of a range of factors: poor
monetary policies, excessive amounts of
inflation, an erosion of the CBRT's
independence, and major economic
deficits that the country has
consistently failed to deal with. In
2020, a single Turkish lira was worth
around 14 US cents. [music] Today, one
lira is worth a little over two cents.
Currencies rise and fall in value all
the time, but Turkey's has suffered much
more than a typical decline. It's been
in a death spiral for several years and
has reached unprecedented [music]
lows in 2026. That's not just bad news
for Turkey's domestic economy. It
becomes a major problem when Ankara
tries to do [music] business with the
rest of the world. With the lira
becoming almost worthless, other
countries across the world are
increasingly unwilling to accept it.
Instead, more often than not, trade
partners want to be paid in US dollars.
So, Turkey has to find a way to get the
dollars. But with the price of a
currency continuing to fall, every
single dollar was more expensive to buy.
In 2020, it only took [music] around
seven lira to purchase $1. In 2026,
Ankara has to hand over close to 50 lira
for that same single [music] dollar
bill. Over time, Turkey has burned
through its currency reserves. Its
economy [music] grew weaker, inflation
skyrocketed, and the country became an
increasingly unappealing proposition for
even the most optimistic [music] of
investors. Still, Turkey was able to
just about hang on. But then something
happened that was entirely out of
Ankara's control. Something that sent
shockwaves across the world, impacting
[music] the entire global economy and
plunging several countries into a state
of serious economic crisis,
>> [music]
>> the war in Iran. In the aftermath of US
bombing runs, Iran blockaded the Strait
of Hormuz, the narrow but critical
waterway that carries around 20% of the
world's oil supply. Almost immediately,
oil prices surged. While every country
felt the impact, the biggest damage was
felt by net energy importers. [music]
The nations that rely on buying oil and
gas from abroad because they can't
produce enough themselves. Turkey is one
of those nations. In fact, it is
incredibly dependent on imported energy.
Despite being [music] a G20 nation with
a strong industrial base, it has almost
no domestic supply of oil or natural
gas. So, all of the fuel that flows into
Turkey effectively comes from other
countries like Russia and Iraq. Soon,
every drop of that fuel suddenly started
to cost much more than the day before.
For some countries, this was manageable.
The US was able to turn to its extensive
oil reserves and domestic production in
order to counteract the crisis. It still
felt the effects as gas and energy
[music] prices still went up, but it had
fail-safes in place. In other countries,
these same kinds [music] of systems
helped to limit the amount of damage
that was done. Turkey, however, suffered
more than most. It suddenly found itself
not [music] only facing far higher
energy bills that needed to be paid
right away, but also an increasingly
weak currency to pay [music] them with.
The longer the war went on without any
sort of diplomatic resolution, the
higher the price of oil went. And as the
price per barrel continued to soar, the
situation only got worse for Ankara
because global energy markets are
merciless. They move fast and they make
concessions for no one, and they only
accept payment in one currency, the US
dollar. Turkey couldn't pursue
alternative means or hope for things to
magically improve. If it wanted to keep
functioning and prevent the struggling
economy from completely sinking, it
needed to get its hands on a large
amount of dollars quickly. If it didn't,
millions of homes would lose power,
hospitals would go dark, and transport
networks would simply stop moving. Food
and other essential goods would stop
[music] flowing, industries would
collapse, and the very existence of the
nation would be plunged into jeopardy.
The CBRT was running out of time. With
its foreign exchange reserves exhausted
and international leaders utterly
unwilling to bail it out, it was forced
to look at the one and only asset it had
left to survive these trying times,
gold. Countries never want to actually
use their gold reserves, but this time,
however, there was no other option. All
of those bars lying around in Turkey's
international vaults no longer looked
like shimmering pieces of insurance and
long-term stores of wealth. Now, they
were the only thing standing between
Turkey and its complete collapse. So,
Turkey made the one and only call it
could. This is where one of the biggest
financial narratives of the last few
years starts to fall apart. For years,
financial commentators pushed the idea
that emerging economies were buying
thousands [music] of tons of gold every
year for one reason, to use it as a
weapon against the West [music] and
specifically against the United States.
The argument was that the BRICS nations,
including Brazil, China, India, Iran,
and Russia, along with their allies,
weren't [music] just protecting
themselves. They were preparing for a
financial revolution. The theory claimed
that these countries were building
enormous amounts of gold reserves
>> [music]
>> so they could create a new global
currency. They wanted to challenge the
dollar's dominance and [music] weaken
America's economy. Eventually, the world
would be forced into a completely
different financial system. It was a
dramatic story, a coordinated plan to
end the dollar era and create a new
world order. But reality didn't play out
that way. The BRICS gold-backed currency
theory has started to collapse under the
weight of what's actually happening in
the real world. And [music] the proof is
all around us, not just in Turkey.
Because Ankara isn't the only one to
sell off its gold. It is just the first
name in an increasingly long [music]
list of global powers. Data from early
2026 shows that numerous other nations,
including members [music] of the BRICS
alliance, have also made moves to
liquidate some of their gold reserves.
Russia broke a 24-year record in the
first 4 months of 2026. Moscow's Central
Bank sold off more of its gold reserves
in April than any other month since
2005. [music] Russia found itself facing
the prospect of economic collapse due to
the ongoing war with Ukraine. Seeing no
other option, it dumped its reserves.
Other countries have followed suit with
emerging markets quietly executing their
own liquidations. [music] Meanwhile,
China and India have remained
tight-lipped in regard to their
gold-related activities. None of this
lines up with the BRICS conspiracy. If
these countries were supposedly so keen
on stockpiling gold to destabilize the
West, then why were so many of them
selling off hundreds of tons of it? The
truth is actually much grimmer than the
conspiracy theorists ever imagined. The
gold hordes that dozens of countries
accumulated over the last decade weren't
supposed to be used as weapons to
destroy the West or dismantle [music]
the dollar. They weren't offensive at
all. They were defensive. These hordes
were financial lifeboats. The leadership
groups and central banks of those
nations realized that their domestic
economies were fragile. They understood
that their currencies could fail
someday. [music]
They realized that a global crisis could
impact their systems and people more
than the wealthier countries of the
world. So, in order to actually take
back some semblance of control, they
turned to gold. They banked as much of
it as they could so they would have
something to fall back on. Gold was a
safety net, but that net is being torn
apart as we speak. Turkey's net simply
has more holes in it than the rest. But,
it's only a matter of time until the
exact same situation plays out in
Africa, in Asia, in Latin America, and
beyond. The circumstances will differ
just as they do between Turkey and
Russia, but the end result will be the
same. Hoards will no longer be hoarded,
but consumed. When the lira lost its
value and the reserves were drained,
Turkey did the national equivalent of a
pawn shop exchange, a gold-for-foreign
exchange swap. Because when it
liquidated its gold, and didn't haul in
$8 billion dollars of gold bullion out
of its vaults and then load it into
planes. Instead, it essentially gave its
gold reserves to international bullion
banks as a form of collateral. In
exchange, those banks then wired
billions of US dollars to Ankara's
accounts. It's like someone who has
money tied up in businesses and
investments, but then suddenly needs
some cash to cover an emergency bill.
They don't want to sell their assets
permanently, so they take a luxury car
to a high-end pawn shop, [music]
use it as collateral, and they walk away
with cash. If their situation improves,
they then repay the money and they get
their car back. If not, the pawn shop
gets to keep it. That's essentially how
Turkey's gold swap works. The country
may be able to recover its gold, but
only by repaying the billions it
received plus interest. Given the
pressure Ankara is facing, recovering
that gold may be easier said than done,
but either way, the irony is impossible
to ignore. For years, the world was told
that countries like Turkey were
stockpiling gold to destabilize the
dollar. The idea was that gold would
help break America's financial
dominance. Yet, when the crisis arrived,
Turkey had to sell the gold to get the
very dollars it was supposedly trying to
escape. It wasn't a global financial
revolution. It was just a reminder that
when things get serious, the world still
runs back to the same currency it's
trusted for generations, the US dollar.
What's happening in Turkey isn't just a
one-off crisis. It's a warning sign of a
global system under growing pressure. A
major G20 economy was forced to
liquidate its most valuable reserves
just to afford basic energy. It had to
smash the emergency glass and drain a
rainy day fund it took years to build,
not to fund expansion, but to keep
factories running and homes heated. That
isn't normal. It's not the sign of a
healthy financial system that's
functioning as intended. It's the sign
of a system that is running on empty,
suffering a truly unprecedented shortage
of worldwide liquidity. But Turkey isn't
the only canary in the coal mine.
Because if energy prices continue to
increase and the US dollar continues to
hold such sway over world markets, the
problem isn't going to go away. It's
going to appear more and more
frequently. Other cash-starved countries
are facing mounting debts, failing
currencies, and they'll have no choice
but to sell their gold. This is the
damning reality. The great gold rush of
the late 2010s and 2020s didn't
culminate with some new financial world
order. Instead, [music] it's leading us
toward a grand global hangover. The
first dominoes of national insolvency
are already falling by the wayside.
Safety nets are being reluctantly yet
actively torn apart, and the global
economic machine is swiftly running out
of room to maneuver. The dollar has been
the default currency for decades, but
now nations are looking for
alternatives. Watch why so many
countries are abandoning the dollar to
find out why, or click on this video.